Netflix's adaptation of the travels and
travails of the mutated monster hunter
Geralt are based on Andrzej Sapkowski 's
long-running series of novels and short
stories and not on the popular Witcher
videogame trilogy but the CD Projekt RED
games are a massive hit across the world
and The Witcher series writer and
showrunner Lawrence Schmidt hiss Rick
knows it that's precisely why as
historic began adapting the high fantasy
world and laying out for season one
narrative
she was sure to leave some room for an
obvious nod or two to those who entered
the fabled world through their consoles
while history holds several iconic
monsters men in moments from sub cows
keys extensive novels she made sure to
slip in a bathing scene between lovers
Geralt of Rivia and mage yennefer that
had become wildly popular among fans of
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt fishing fortune
seems an extreme measure to remedy
sleeplessness Oh an extreme measures
seem reasonable
yes I'm desperate the bathtub Geralt
scene is featured during the game's
opening sequence and captures an
intimate feral moment between the
monster slayer and is on-again off-again
partner yennefer by the looks of it they
both somewhat settled down with universe
charge princess ciri at San Diego
comic-con 2019 history first alluded
that some form of the scene would appear
on the Netflix show
she told io9 there is a bathtub scene
this season there is a bathtub I will
tell you who's in the bathtub but there
is a bathtub for those who are new to
the witcher universe when the Netflix
series first dropped the moment might
have felt like one among many gratuitous
shirtless scenes but it actually holds a
broader significance the bathtub Geralt
scene opens The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt and
is somewhat beloved forb of course
giving gamers a glimpse of Geralt both
in the nude and providing a rare
intimate moment with the woman he loves
relaxing in a hot tub within his chamber
at The Witcher Academy known as Kara
Morin in the game Jerald - scene with
his feet and arms hanging over the sides
of a wooden tub we then see him jolt up
and remove a crustacean like creature
from his private parts
you know I don't find that amusing it
takes only a moment for it to become
clear that the animal isn't real and is
instead of magical prodding delivered by
the naked but strategically positioned
sorceress yennefer Geralt promised ciri
he trained with her and yennefer wants
him to get on with it
so the moment ends with Geralt
begrudgingly exiting the tub walking
over to the mage and engaging in a
passionate kiss before stomping off to
meet up with ciri it's not particularly
long and not especially exciting but it
does offer up a different side of the
life of Geralt one where he doesn't have
to be all sword wielding and blood
splatter the scenes a slice-of-life
moment that helps flesh out the Witcher
games key characters the moment within
the Netflix series is somewhat different
with geralt and yennefer mostly teasing
one another as the issue around the
Djinn an air genie that causes chaos
looms the sorceress even joins the
monster slayer of Rivia and the steamy
hot soap but like The Witcher 3 sequence
it's mostly about the verbal tit-for-tat
geralt and yennefer are known for the
inclusion of the scene in the show was
for showrunner history a very
intentional olive branch for video game
fans
she told GamesRadar it's fun to visually
throw a wink and a nod at video game
fans to say we see you too we know
you're here and we want them to be happy
with what we're doing as well while it's
not clear if we'll get any more steamy
scenes featuring Geralt the baby Beauty
on the show's second season season one's
bare chested peaky kneecap action will
surely suffice in the meantime for
gamers and casual oglers alike check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]